[Music]
wundabar
arms up like this happy family please
look into the camera please just been
through a lot lately my dad passed away
eight months ago so we came here to here
to here you lose a parent and the
ticking gets louder every day is all we
have yep
maybe we ski the Beast after lunch
I don't think it would be that
challenging it'll be fine is that okay
yeah it's fine
it looked like it was gonna kill us for
a moment
the kids were screaming because it felt
like we were gonna die hate and I look
over Kate and he had grabbed his phone
Kate left us life I didn't believe you
to be buried yeah I'm gonna win I ran to
get out I love my family okay run away
in ski boots
what can you run a ski boots not very
well exactly
regardless I wouldn't leave my family to
die that's Boone usual right to be angry
it's black and white
well no it's black and white how old are
you 30
oh there's only one thing I have to
worry about right now and that's going
down
I don't understand why there weren't any
warnings posted anywhere there was why
why posted eye lifts gondolas hotel
receptions restaurants shops Baris
solutions sites we didn't see any of
that well
[Music]